what do you hope for the future
innovation safety creativity freedom
drives the futures usually painted as
pretty bleak isn't it
politics pollution pestilence poverty
sort of running out of negative Peas
parsnips they're not nice but here's a
positive P perspective in reality people
around the world are working right now
to build a better future for us all
researchers designers and developers are
constantly expanding the boundaries of
our potential and it's thrilling in
these films we'll be exploring a little
of the Hope hidden behind the horrible
headlines we have thrown at us every day
this film is going to explore one
technology that's going to reshape the
cities of the future autonomous cars and
now let's move from these beautifully
crafted images to a forty eight-year-old
dollop talking to an expert listen I've
always wanted to stand in a field with a
health and safety expert thank god I've
got the best safety Susie can you give
me a window into how dangerous driving a
car really is it's something I do just
as a matter of course every day and I
never really think about risk how risky
is it driving is one of the riskiest
things that you will do we make lots of
mistakes when we drive we're not really
designed to whiz around at 70 miles an
hour and experience traffic and make
judgments at that kind of speed 71
people are killed or seriously injured
every single day in the UK in Great
Britain yeah if you translated their
speakers to other modes of transport
trains planes I mean no one would get in
an aircraft if someone said 71 people
died or seriously injured in one of
those things Road traffic crashes
leading cause of death of all causes of
death for 15 to 29 year olds all causes
of death and you just don't know you
know but why don't I know that really
what's important to recognize we know
how to fix the problem does that
represent for you coming you know from a
safety point of view just like a sort of
Nirvana it's kind of the future isn't it
this kind of thing yes it doesn't give
you the thrill of being a petrol head
etc but actually for me valuing human
life is so much more enforcement the
most important motivation at hand here
is safety when you look at the
statistics and see that more than 90% of
all accidents on the road are due to
driver inattention there's a huge
potential for increasing safety there
now think about an autonomous vehicle is
it
never be not paying attention whereas
you can only look in one direction at
the time autonomous vehicles are we
looking all 360 degrees around them at
all times so to that extent it is kind
of superhuman acts are have been
involved right from the very start with
autonomous vehicles and they have a very
active role to play because it is so
crucial to the acceptance and the actual
introduction of the technology it can't
happen unless there are insurance
procedures in place we have the chance
now to design a mechanism which in some
ways can do better than human being
isn't it something about being human
that we're hardwired to push ourselves
and speed is part of that we want to go
so fast as possible I think it's the
connection with the car for someone like
myself that I get the task of driving
them on the track and on the limit is
where I enjoy it most
what's your mode of transport normally
the most practical form of transport for
me comes in the family car yeah I've got
two young kids so security is one big
thing making sure that they are safe how
would your kids feel about getting into
something like this I mean we've been
quite commonly about it but they find it
excited I'm quite interested to see my
kids especially because they've been
around racetracks that's something
they're not going to get the chance to
do drive their own car will they even
need a driving license the key thing I
would imagine about this is it is safe
I mean much as we love cars you can't
override the fact that it's a dangerous
pursuit it is a dangerous pursuit
exactly and this should take the human
element of driving and can use that
quality time in here whether you're
going to the Duke school run whether
you're going somewhere else it's
actually to write to your kids a bit
more how dare you
[Music]
without any mysterion
are you sorry no you think I'm staring
how do you feel about the future happy
open-minded so we originally got
involved in driverless vehicles because
we were really engaged with a local
charity called beacon Center for the
blind so he wanted to try and help
people that are both partially sighted
and mobility impaired it's gonna enable
them to be socially inclusive it's going
to enable them to travel without the
need for somebody to help them so it's
gonna give them some independence which
they've never had before we've been
working really closely with accent to
look at preventing accidents we've been
looking at vehicle design but most
importantly to make this a success at a
safe success it's brought tears to
people's eyes here in the factory the
fact that we can actually change
somebody's life for the better I'm here
with a group of people whose needs
historically have never been met by the
motoring community but that's is about
to change
so pongy tell us a little bit about
yourself I represented a group of you
know elderly people I've got Elliston
life syndrome unfortunately all the
joints would dislocate on a daily basis
I used to climb at mountains all sorts
of things like that and then one day I
broke my ankle and it didn't heal
properly we've always kind of suspected
autism I've been left at 1 year old so
what I think of needs being met in a car
I never consider the needs of somebody
who is deaf humanize that when I Drive
an old engine
everyone team notes so are the emblems
maybe about here the emblems until it's
not behind it so how would an automated
car make things better what a point of
view we didn't order a toilet that's
your chill time fantastic actually you
know it's actually freedom it'd be a lot
easier in terms of mobility yeah to be
able to just wheel in and go and not
have to take the chair apart that's
where you get there take a chair out
again put butt together fantastic what
will we need most in the future trust
compassion there's a common
misconception that we talk about
everything being in the future and we've
kind of not realized how much time has
passed things like driverless cars were
talked about for ages and I'm standing
next to one right now so I think people
haven't quite realized how far into the
future we are yet so it's easy for
addicts like me to think that technology
is completely removed not only from my
life but removed in time so these things
you know that we talked about you know
generations away but in fact I've just
seen a six-year-old operated you know
drone with a wave of their hands
how much does this represent a leap
forward view it means people can become
more flexible and it's where previously
some of them had some difficulties
traveling straight away they become
connected I think in general if
technology could help people to connect
with whichever more which is having more
time to interact with your family and
friends this isn't the end of the
discussion it's just the beginning but
as I've learned today it's a
conversation that we're all a part of
it's not them and us it's not scientist
versus the rest of the world we can all
work together and inform a future that
is better for all of us a few years ago
during what I thought was a routine
blood test I discovered I had a lump on
my brain thankfully a very benign lump
we like to think of ourselves as
immortal we don't want to see the full
stop my diagnosis was a shock I felt
alone and suddenly disconnected from my
body
but if we choose to explore our bodies
the possibility of hope is endless this
is the second of three films exploring
axes role in research that's changing
our lives for the better I don't know
about you but I've often grown up
thinking it's nature versus nurture like
the two were mutually exclusive concepts
but what if they're not what have you
got your genetic blueprint but could do
things in your life here and now that
made your chances of living a longer
life better I'm off to meet a guy who
unlocks the secrets of our bodies and
helps us to live better now Peter I'm
someone who running slightly country to
the flow is not tired of experts I love
an expert and you're the main man here
today tell me what the AXA funding has
meant for you and the work that you do
the actual funding has been fundamental
to my research that I've been able to
look at how DNA differences between you
and I might affect how long each of us
live the AXA Research Fund is interested
in funding research about some of the
big themes in our society things like
big data things like climate change so I
put forward my proposal to study how DNA
affects lifespan and when it comes to
analyzing genetics presumably there is
no more interesting case study than
twins that's right so twins have been
the cornerstone of much genetic research
for a long long time in what Saints are
particularly identical trends truly
identical so we see things like eye
color whether your hair is curly then a
lot of the more interesting traits are
not necessarily identical to them and
for me things like two identical twins
will often not suffer from the same
diseases the lawn was certainly not live
exactly the same amount of time I'm Ross
I'm Hugo and we're the Tanner twins we
got fun expeditions all over the world
and as we're twins it allows medical
research teams to study how our bodies
are affected in extreme environments
individually we're not that interesting
but I guess as a huge research study and
you build out it then suddenly starts
becoming an incredibly valuable data set
so it's a really really exciting to kind
of be part of some pioneering research
as twins that we can kind of go off and
do our expeditions and come at it from a
slightly different angle I mean my dad
has an identical twin and
he went on to develop three primary
cancers over 20 years and my and
possibly two years ago and my uncle
still alive and thriving and has never
ever been been touched with it with a
day of cancer I don't think a lot of
people know actually how much research
time effort professionalism you know the
greatest minds in the world are actually
working on problems that we might not
appreciate now but in 10 20 years time
the advances in medical research and
understanding and the techniques that
are able to treat such conditions will
be so so far beyond what they are today
you've given good data for that we thank
you god I am for you look at you how
much would you say our lives are
dependent on genes and how much it's
predicated on things like lifestyle
healthy eating exercise and I sort of
start about a sixth of how long we live
for example is under direct genetic
control the rest of it's about
environment and in fact the interaction
between those two things I'm actually
surprised by what a small number that is
actually because sometimes you feel like
you're under the cosh of your own
heredity you know you sort of feel that
oh I'm born with this sort of genetic
sequencing that's absolutely going to
dictate but you're saying that really we
have so much free will in terms of how
we navigate our health and well-being
absolutely you and I both have about
three billion letters in this huge
genome that we keep hearing about and
what I'm trying to do is understand how
individual pieces of that genome affect
how long we live for me it's it's not
just how long we live but it's how well
we live I think that it's more
fundamental and I think by understanding
the aging process and understanding
susceptibility to disease it's very much
my hope that as we live longer we live
healthier and happier as well when I was
diagnosed things changed suddenly my
insides felt alien like they were
working against me
I was stunned by how little control I
felt I had over my own body but I've
learned today were already much further
along the journey
understanding ourselves and people
thought possible genetic research being
supported by the AXA Research Fund means
we can comprehend our specific needs and
nourish them like all the great moments
in human experience this is possible
because of collaboration scientists
volunteers and those willing to
adventure have combined to unlock the
deepest mysteries within all of us
[Music]